on the house Freedom caucus he's the
policy chair house Judiciary Committee U
knows of what he speaks Congressman um
this effort that the Administration has
had to sue Texas often times for a
variety of things including razor wire
and the rest but constantly battling in
courts um a lot of your colleagues have
been said but not doing enough with
security on the border where are you on
this well Neil obviously since I've been
in Congress I've spent the bulk of my
time trying to elevate this issue bring
attention to the issue and point out
that it is terrible for Texans and
terrible for migrants and I just want to
start this by saying yesterday you know
I've been gone hadn't seen my family for
a number of weeks been out on the
campaign Trail uh came in and Texas went
straight down to bracketville Texas
yesterday spent about three hours with
Ranchers with local law enforcement with
sheriffs local political leaders uh who
are just Des absolutely devastated with
what's going on down in South Texas and
frankly as much as I've tried to do for
them tried to be a voice for them
they're mad they're yelling at me
they're saying saying you know we're
tired of the the the rhetoric we're
tired of more words and look there's a
lot of noise that is surrounding all of
this with the razor wire now down in
Eagle Pass the fact is I totally support
Governor Abbott 100% has my backing to
do that and go further but the fact of
the matter is we're still allowing
thousands to pour into our country
because they're just going around the
razor wire and coming into ports of
entry and other places and the Biden
Administration is using parole and
Asylum to dump them into our country
which is upending our security
empowering cart tells and allowing
fentel and Bad actors to come in between
the ports of Entry so I applaud picking
the fight I'm glad there are Republican
Governors around the nation that are
saying we stand with Greg Abbot in Texas
but okay now what do you really stand
with us are you sending the National
Guard are you going to tell President
Biden to pound sand that we're not going
to follow whatever nonsense he's trying
to force upon the people because it's
not just Texas the whole country is made
weaker for this so we've got to get
serious about this and my last point is
House Republicans have got to stop
funding the government that is at war
with the people and Senate Republicans
have got to stop trying to cut a deal
that has no chance of Passage through
the house and no chance of actually
securing the Border you talked about
these Governors who have signed on to in
in support of Governor Abbott among them
is Ronda sanis the candidate you were
backing for president didn't end well
for him what do you think of what
happened and now the move of foot by the
RNC to look to Donald Trump as the
presumptive nominee with only two states
having
voted well I mean Governor Des has put
his money where his is he sent National
Guard there years ago uh that he's been
sending support to Texas he's been out
there advocating and a number of the
other Governors I was on the campaign
trail with Governor stit others that
have been very helpful uh but let let's
be very clear uh president Trump is 100%
right that the Senate GOP should not be
cutting a deal with the administration
but let me be also clear not just for
political reasons right it shouldn't be
for political purposes to say oh we want
this issue to be live through the
campaign no I want this border to be
secured today
so I want House Republicans to stand up
I want Senate Republicans to stand up so
I'm with President Trump no deal but I
am with uh house conservatives to say
that we need to stand up and force a
funding fight between now and the end of
February to say guys you don't get to
keep doing this they're funding the
United Nations that is moving these
people through through a systematic
scheme IND dangering us and empowering
cartels they're funding United Nations
that's funding Hamas they're funding at
my orcus DHS that is at war with the
people of Texas suing Us in court why
would any Republican do that so if
you're watching this call your
Republican member of Congress and say
why are you funding the people that are
making our country less secure and that
are undermining our freedoms that should
end this month so you would be if it
pushes the government to the brink and a
shutdown better that than to accept a
water down security
measure Neil we are at such a point of
desperation this isn't about political
theater and shutdowns this is is about
simply a simple question when the
founders gave us the power of the purse
Federalist 58 James Madison it was
specifically to stop an executive branch
that is ignoring the law and acting
tyrannically that is what is happening
here we have a duty to do that I think
we need to have that fight if
Republicans aren't willing to do that
why are Republicans in the majority um
sir I I I meant to pass along to your
former speaker Kevin McCarthy was
fingering the the house Freedom caucus
for getting nothing done and sort of
trying to extract concessions I I I'm
I'm interpreting here for for for
bringing us to this sprink not this
particular one but several of them what
what do you make of
that well look I was working with Kevin
all last year frankly and I'm not going
to get in the middle of that Skirmish or
whatever he said or didn't say but I'll
say this we did a lot of good things for
the first half of last year we passed
the best border Bill we've ever passed
we passed limit save grow which would
have actually responsibly increase the
debt a mere $1 a. half trillion dollars
for serious changes we passed a good
defense uh ndaa bill that would have
restored our military to its Mission we
passed seven Appropriations bills 1100
amendments we were restoring regular
order I disagreed with the motion to
vacate last September now here we sit I
wish we weren't here I think that some
people in the freedom caucus got that
wrong I think some people that are not
in the freedom caucus love to spend
people's money in the unip party and
keep doing the same business as usual
the American people want us to actually
responsibly change the town that's what
I've been trying to do I've been trying
to call out my fre caucus colleagues
when they get it wrong I've been trying
to call out the uni party establishment
when they keep spending money keep
empowering defense keep getting us in
Endless Wars and next week we're going
to do another corporate tax cut bill I
support some of those policies but how
do we look at the American people and
say oh we're the party of endless Wars
and tax cuts but our borders are open
and we keep spending money we don't have
they want us to be responsible so that's
what I'm trying to fight for in in my
perch in Washington um I did touch on
very briefly sir of this RNC move to to
make Donald Trump the presumptive
nominee uh Nikki Haley has criticized
that move essentially saying let the
voters in the Republican Party decide
that uh I know Ronda sandis was your
candidate not Nikki heli but I'm just
curious what you make of that is that a
little too soon to be making anyone a
presumptive
nominee well first let me say that I
think Nikki with all due respect he kind
of represents that old guard of the
Republican party that I just was kind of
lambasting that's big spending and all
defense and you know endless Wars I
think we need to move a different
direction I think president Trump
represented in 2016 a challenge to The
Establishment a you know challenge to
drain the swamp but I don't think we
should be coronating somebody I went out
and campaigned in Iowa we don't coronate
people you know we don't just choose
somebody and you know you get anointed
uh go through the process go earn it uh
because it makes you sharper in the
general election so uh you know if he
doesn't think that he has anything to
worry about then don't worry about it Go
campaign and go win uh he should be able
to win in South Carolina based on I
think the electorate in South Carolina
so we should proceed with the electoral
process and uh if he's ultimately the
nominee by votes then he should be
supported as the nominee for the
Republican party but you got to go earn
it you don't just get coronated got it
um Congressman always good seeing you
thank you for taking the time